new attacks in Afghanistan this morning
have killed 19 security personnel
officials say eight of them were gunned
down by a fellow police officer that
follows yesterday's double bombing at a
wrestling Club in Kabul that killed 21
people including two Afghan journalists
and injured nearly 90 more Charlie
d'Agata is in Kabul with the sudden
spike in violence charlie good morning
good morning well a Sports Club clearly
a civilian target meant to kill as many
people as possible and today Pierre part
broken families are waking up to the
reality they will never see their loved
ones again Isis today claimed
responsibility for the bombings in that
Hsieh neighborhood emergency workers and
journalists became victims when a car
bomb blew up after that first explosion
sergeant major Timothy bull yard gave up
his life in an effort to stop that kind
of violence he was shot dead by an
Afghan police officer he came here to
train as part of his mission
it was his seventh overseas deployment
six bronze medals two for valor it
followed another insider attack that
killed 20 year old corporal Joseph Maceo
in July and yet just yesterday US
Secretary of Defense James Madison that
reconciliation here is no longer a
mirage well it may seem like a mirage to
the families of fallen US servicemen
returning home
Norah all right charlie thank you